bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur tv fil 78 si vous nous rejoignez
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
le thème de ce soir la réforme du
collège faut-il ou pas sont inquiétés
vous pouvez réagir participer poser
toutes vos questions sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtag 7,8 société qu'est-ce
qui va concrètement changer dans le
travail des enseignants dans la
pédagogie et dans le contenu des
programmes est ce la fin de
l'enseignement du latin et du grec
pourquoi cette réforme portée par najat
vallaud belkacem fait-elle temps réagir
à droite mais également à gauche pour
répondre à ces questions trois invités
autour de la table sandrine grillé
d'abord qui est un professeur d'anglais
qui a été professeur en tant que les six
ans en collège et qui est maintenant au
lycée et surtout secrétaire général du
syndicat d'enseignants se gainent cfdt à
l'académie de versailles bonsoir
christian taillebois qui est délégué
départemental du parti chrétien
démocrate en soient bons soins et enfin
xavier faire un argus secrétaire fédéral
du parti socialiste en charge de
l'éducation
alors pour commencer cette émission un
chiffre apparemment selon un sondage au
doxa près de deux tiers des français
sont opposés à la réforme du collège
alors on va commencer à rentrer dans le
vif du sujet parler du contenu de la
réforme pour comprendre ce qui va
changer concrètement alors au niveau des
programmes pour commencer ce sont
surtout les programmes d'histoire entre
autres qui sont très critiqués avec
l'introduction des terrains obligatoire
et de thèmes facultatif qu'est ce qui
pose selon vos problèmes dans cette
distinction cette différenciation entre
le facultatif et le week end noir pour
commencer alors peut-être qu'avant de
parler
des programmes parce qu'en réalité il ya
une réforme des collèges et une réforme
des programmes il ya deux éléments qui
je crois doivent être distingués à la
fois dans les modalités de consultation
et une mise en oeuvre moi ce qui me
frappe peut-être en introduction c'est
la méthode de la ministre
entêtement tout on est contre à droite à
gauche très sélective
mais vous avez cité un chiffre qui
concerne les français et c'est
finalement le plus important mais aussi
beaucoup d'intellectuels
de responsables politiques de droite et
de gauche je les dis
bref pourquoi pourquoi cet entêtement
mépris pour ceux qui ne partagent pas
l'avis de la ministre et du gouvernement
on a entendu
les immobiles dénoncé par par le
président hollande qui soutient sa
ministre et puis l'absence de
concertation vous l'avez dit de dire des
français sont contre cette réforme ce
projet de réforme aujourd'hui des
enseignants nombreux ils sont
significativement mobilisés sont dans la
rue et ça reste c'est évidemment très
significatif
les parents d'élèves sont sont contre
vous avez cité le chiffre qu'on
construit pas une réforme durablement
quand on a tout le monde contre soi
alors ce qui me gêne un petit peu dans
ce que je viens d'entendre c'est le fait
d'un groupe qui n'a pas du tout eu de
concertation c'est faux
les représentants des personnels et
syndicats sont en discussion depuis un
petit moment avec madame la ministre
entendre que la majorité des français
est contre alors qu'il ya eu un vote au
csc le comité supérieur de l'éducation
qui a été majoritairement pour sachez
encore que migros est alors beaucoup
demandent les associations de parents
d'élèves les associations pédagogiques
les représentants des syndicats des
enseignants mais aussi des syndicats
90 aignan qui représente la société
civile enfin on a un panel assez
représentatifs de la société française
et ce comité est supérieur à plutôt voté
pour un très large majorité mais ce
n'est plus le cas en tout cas de
syndicats d'enseignants alors les
implications sont contre cette réforme
absolument mais c'est toujours les mêmes
donc ça on pourrait en débattre dans le
monde des heures et pendant longtemps de
toute façon quand il ya une réforme dans
l'éducation
les gens sont contre par principe à
juste quand même une petite chose moi
j'aimerais bien savoir si les gens qui
se sont exprimés sur ce sondage alors
critiqué la méthode du sondage on lui la
réforme parce que s'ils avaient lu je me
demande s'il aura été réellement contre
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont dites
l'opinion publique elle se fait par
rapport à ce qui est diffusé dans des
médias et ma foi
il est quand même une certaine une
certaine partialité même si récemment on
entend un petit peu plus la voix de ceux
qui sont pour javier verlag oui moi je
crois qu'il faut partir d'un constat et
revenir un petit peu 40 ans en arrière
c'est à dire se dire que la réforme haby
de 75 le collège unique pardon le
collège unique de le collège unique donc
je vois relatives au collège unique d'un
constat qu'on peut faire c'est que on a
démocratisé l'accès on n'a pas
démocratise la réussite
jusqu'à quand peut-on se satisfaire le
laisser sur le bord du chemin
cent quarante mille élèves qui sortent
du système scolaire sans qualification
ensuite que déplore-t-on au fil du temps
pour en arriver
estimait ce qui relève du bia feront de
cette réforme
quand luc ferry est arrivé au ministère
d'éducation nationale en 2002 sa
première mesure ça était de supprimer le
haut conseil à l'innovation pédagogique
les travaux du conseil il ya bientôt
quinze ans préconisait que pour
effectivement démocratiser la réussite
des élèves il fallait parler d'
accompagnement pédagogique il fallait
parler d'interdisciplinarité c'est ce
que nous propose la ministre aujourd'hui
donc c'est un débat tient sur un fil
entre le président sarkozy a fait ce que
nul démocraties d'europe a osé faire
avant lui la suppression de la formation
pédagogique des enseignants la
suppression des iufm
les relations des yeux
avec l'oublions pas quatre-vingt mille
postes d'enseignants supprimés
à vrai dire parce que vous nous dit que
les choses vont pas bien et c'est vrai
d'ailleurs la ministre semble d'accord
tout le monde semble avoir sur le
diagnostic tout le monde est d'accord et
qui ne peut pas l'être d'ailleurs en
voyant les chiffres et la ministre est
même rappelait je crois cité dans le
monde n'est pas très longtemps 22 % des
collégiens ne maîtrise pas les
connaissances de base en mathématiques
21% en histoire-géo 19% en lecture et la
réforme elle propose quoi pour répondre
à ce constat de difficultés elle propose
de rogner progressivement sur les
enseignements de base sur les langues
anciennes sur certains pans de
l'histoire alors ça c'est la réforme des
programmes on est on est d'accord
justement en danger que ce sujet sur ses
sept parties continuent alors je finisse
renier sur des enseignements
fondamentaux pour ouvrir du temps de
l'espace à des ateliers alors sur les
blogs sur les recherches sur internet
sur plein de choses comme ça tu senti
également sur les cultures antiques
c'est à dire on va faire des maquettes
de pyramide on va faire des choses comme
ça bon pourquoi pas on pourrait se le
permettre si l'ensemble des des
collégiens avaient un socle de
connaissances pardon solides
permettant de former leur jugement
permettant de former leurs réflexions
donc aujourd'hui pour répondre à ce
constat de difficultés d'une grande
partie des collégiens on fait quoi on
met en avant des matières périphériques
et des ateliers ludiques c'est pas
sérieux comme si ces matières
périphériques allait prendre la place
d'autres fonderies vous êtes d'accord
avec ça ça m'ennuie beaucoup d'entendre
ça parce que ça veut dire que comme moi
j'étais au collège m'a dit dont j'ai
fait des grosses bêtises en matière
pédagogique c'est à dire que j'étais
déjà en interdisciplinarité
je peux leur verdict vous répétiez
peut-être pour ceux qui savent pas ce
que c'est l'interdisciplinarité c'est
quand vous avez des professeurs de
différentes disciplines qui décident
ensemble de monter un projet de
travailler ensemble pour faire
progresser les élèves je peux vous
donner un exemple concret très rapide
dans le collège où j'ai été enseignante
y avait une petite classe de sixième une
sixième on accueillait des élèves qui
étaient on va dire en difficulté qui
arrivait avec des lacunes donc il y
avait une équipe motivée et on avait un
projet pluridisciplinaire maths français
histoire géo anglais est le point commun
toutes ces disciplines c'est qu'on
travaillait sur une pièce de théâtre
donc les professeurs de français
d'histoire géo ont travaillé sur la
rédaction donc les élèves ont écrit une
pièce de théâtre on est complètement
dans l'interdisciplinarité et comme la
pièce de théâtre ça parlait du roi
arthur et bien par moments il y avait
des phrases en anglais c'est là que
j'entrais dedans et le professeur de
mathématiques quant à lui travaillait
sur et bien les décors et professeur de
technologie j'ai oublié pardon donc
travailler sur des calculs de mesure et
c'est ce genre de chose travailler sur
des calculs donc là on était vraiment
dans un projet pluridisciplinaire que ça
va marcher sa basse a extrêmement bien
marché et là il ya une très grande
fierté dans la première promotion il ya
un des étudiants qui cette année est
stagiaire professeurs et alors ça fait
toujours plaisir d'entendre ça quand on
est enseignant alors c'est toujours une
joie 610 revoir rendre légitime une
réforme on prend un cas particulier et
très bien et bravo et moi je ne doute
absolument pas de vos compétences ni de
celle des enseignants d'ailleurs mais
voilà il ya vous avez une belle
expérience autour de ça moi ce que je
vois et c'est pas c'est pas moi c'est un
constat c'est que le niveau global des
élèves à la sortie du collège baisse
donc ils vont peut-être s'interroger là
dessus et je crois vraiment que la
réponse n'est pas de développer
plus de temps d'interdisciplinarité je
ne m'oppose pas par principe à 7,7 à son
travail et même et je crois que vraiment
il faut mettre le paquet sur les
fondamentaux et que nos enfants sachent
lire écrire et compter
convenablement et mieux comptablement
parfaitement la sortie du collège c'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui fermé
oui je crois qu'on a un petit peu mal à
partager cette curieuse conception de la
république
qui consisterait à considérer toute
politique conçue pour ouvrir les chemins
de la réussite aux élèves un nivellement
par le bas de quoi s'agit-il de notre
point de vue quand il s'agit
effectivement mettre en place des
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire les élèves
apprendront à coopérer pour mener
ensemble un projet plutôt que de
s'affronter aux autres dans une
compétition individualiste mais c'est
pas ça que maintenant les en renforçant
le suivi personnalisé dont ont besoin
tous les élèves pour construire leur
parcours de réussite
je crois que c'est ça dont il s'agit
quand on parle d'un agrément par le bas
c'est la première monsieur faire la
glisse et quand la ministre parle de
classe trop élitiste qu'on devrait
supprimer c'est aussi ne peut être
écouté et de l'idéologie qu'il a du mal
à se faire à l'idée qu'il s'agirait de
continuer avec un service public qui
n'exerceraient pas son propre recours en
cas de dysfonctionnement est un service
public il n'exerçait plus on frotte son
propre congrès dysfonctionnements ne
bénéficient plus de mon point de vue de
ce label service public de cette
conception de service public quel est le
constat sur le système actuel vous avez
donc l'état qui dépense plus de deux
fois plus pour les 15% d'élèves qui
réussissent le mieux au détriment des
15% qui réussissent le mois
donc il s'agit effectivement de mettre
en synergie au travers de cette réforme
toutes les formes d'intelligence qui
habite chaque élève sachant que les
chronobiologistes les spécialistes et
pédopsychiatre nous dit le travers
majeur de l'éducation nationale c'est de
favoriser une seule forme d'intelligence
que les spécialistes qualifient du
verbeau conceptuel au lieu de mettre en
synergie les formes d'intelligence sur
les pédagogie de projet bien pensé et
qui amène les enfants à opérer et là on
avait mal en khl c'est justement comment
on fait concrètement pour mettre en
place ce que vous venez de dire comment
on fait concrètement brackley les ans
est adapté dick interdisciplinaire
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire peuvent répondre à
cette question alors je crois que la
concertation lancée puisque reçu
effectivement disait la ministre tente
de passer à la hussarde sans pied de
concertation préalable
la concertation a eu lieu en amont en
amont du vote du ce et ceux qui comme le
rappelait magazine donc quand c'est
super et l'éducation s'est prononcé dans
une malle l'autorité d'un peu plus des
deux tiers pour effectivement le
principe de cette réforme mais
actuellement navigant il faut en effet
que j'aborde la concertation aille à son
terme je crois que le conseil national
du programme a rendu des avis qui sont d
avis provisoire la concertation continue
il faut effectivement que les acteurs de
l'école puisse s'en saisir de façon à ce
que la réforme aille à son terme je vous
laisse un mot rapidement viol et viol
amour pardon madame la vie des cinq ans
vous dit quand vous dites concertation
etc non le message qu'on voit la
ministre aujourd'hui aux grévistes et
manifestants c'est circulez ya rien à
voir de toute façon on y va et c'est le
même message que l'on voit ou deux tiers
des français qui sont opposés à cette
réforme donc excusez moi mais en termes
de concertation de dialogue le
gouvernement socialiste peut beaucoup
mieux faire tu feras mais de vendre très
rapidement
c'est pas le sentiment qu'on apprend te
regarde
vous avez effectivement sur sept
départements dans chaque académie un
certain nombre d'instances paritaires
d'instances de concertation
avez vous entendu parler mais klezmer
structure d'instance aujourd'hui à des
manifestants dansent de course était
terminée décisionnaire mais je crois
effectivement la communauté éducative
s'est emparé du sujet avant
effectivement que la droite ne
s'emparent effectivement des médias pour
faire ce qui relève de notre point de
vue de l'enfumage je crois effectivement
que si on arrive à retrouver un petit
peu de raisons on s'apercevra très vite
du bien fondé de cette réforme on va en
reparler je vous donne la parole juste
après son âme veillée nous sommes allés
demander aux saint quentinois ce qu'il
pensait de cette réforme du collège on
regarde j'ai entendu aussi que vous les
supprimez le latin et ça je trouve que
c'est un peu dommage même si ça peut
sembler parfois élitiste ça concourt
quand même
à la culture générale les langues mortes
ce peut-être moins indispensable mais
après tout certaines personnes en ont
envie pourquoi les supprimer aussi le
latin c'est très important surtout pour
les élèves qui veut faire la lettre
c'est très important mais pour les gens
qui veulent faire l'économie s'est pas
vraiment du temps pourtant à l'élan
glaçage et moitié moins d'avis le
lattage avait pas fait donc je pense
qu'on peut s'en passer mais bon les
langues c'est un autre problème je n'y
suis pas du tout favorable puisque je
suis enseignante en fait jusqu'ici on
avait trois heures en 4ème trois heures
en troisième et maintenant on va voir
exactement le volume horaire mais
étalées sur
sur trois ans à mon avis c'est pas du
tout positif voilà donc on a beaucoup
parlé du latin dans les avis qu'on vient
de voir de ce que pensent les saint
quentinois et les saint quentinois alors
on va d'abord parlé de chiffres pour
parler tu l'attends qui a été une chose
qui a été très mise en avant la
suppression du latin la suppression du
grec alors j'ai des chiffres de la
source du ministère de l'éducation
nationale 20 % d'élèves en cinquième qui
étudie les langues anciennes et on passe
à 17 pour un peu plus de 17% en 4e 15,8
pour cent en troisième et puis quand on
arrive au lycée il n'y a plus que 4 3%
en terminale pour le latin et 1%
seulement pour le grec et pourtant c'est
ce qui semble le plus
intéressé les politiques qui sont contre
cette réforme cependant une grille vous
disait que le latin est important et
fondamental mais pour en discuter avec
les collègues de la dgi envie de dire
que tous les collégiens devraient faire
du latin c'est absolument essentiel
c'est placer la preuve de langue qu'ils
parlent mais c'est l'histoire de la
langue je pense que ça leur
permettraient réellement de progresser
de comprendre comment le français
fonctionne ça leur permettrait vraiment
de de progresser en orthographe ça c'est
indéniable c'est indéniable c'est pour
ça qu'il faut que tout le monde en face
et je crois que c'est ce qui est prévu
dans la passe que c est ce que c'est
parce qu'il est prévu christian jantel
bois dans cette réforme puisque on
casserait ces options latin et grec pour
les re dispatcher via ces fameux
enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire voilà il donc et
diluée dans dans d'autres d'autres coups
au risque d'ailleurs que finalement
progressivement tout ça disparaît c'est
moi je suis vraiment de la vie de madame
c'est important parce que c'est un
effondrement sans fondement linguistique
c'est aussi un effondrement notre
identité culturelle latin série et comme
le grec d'ailleurs donc c'est très très
important parce que c'est c'est lié à
l'identité essayé à ce qu'est notre
culture et c'est pour ça qu'un alors je
vous demande vos coûts si ce si
important pour l'identité française
comment expliquez-vous qui est si peu de
français qu'il la pratique je vais
d'abord tordre le cou à une idée reçue
peut-être qu'on pense que le latin c'est
dans les beaux quartiers dans les
centres villes etc c'est pas vrai savez
vous que là où enfin le latin et le grec
1 les langues anciennes savez vous que
cette
c'est le grec ancien a le plus progressé
non pas à paris ni à versailles ou
ailleurs mais c'était en seine saint
denis voilà donc au cours des dix
dernières années + x 2 pardon la la la
la fréquentation des cours de grec en
dix ans donc en fait on voit bien que
c'est pas ce n'est pas hésiter c'est
simplement parce que il n'ya peut-être
pas toutes les dispositions partout dans
tous les établissements pour qu'il y ait
des classes qui s'ouvre et des élèves
qu'ils puissent pratiquer ces langues et
moi ce que je pensais qu'à force de
détricoter tout cela donc on pourrait
parler aussi de l'histoire on parle des
langues anciennes et à force de
détricoter l'école publique qui va se
passer et c'est là où on va créer de la
vraie inégalité messieurs c'est que on
va se détourner l'école publique et 6
qui ont les moyens d'aller en écoles
privées pourront le faire donc les plus
riches pourront effectivement retrouver
ce type d'enseignement ailleurs si cet
argument a plutôt été balayé par
l'enseignement privé catholique qui est
pour cette réforme et qui disait que
notre toute façon nous allons aussi
appliquer cette réforme et ils ont mis
en avant le fait que les collèges allait
être plus autonome alors moi je n'ai pas
à commenter une décision de deux
millions de français qui sont dans les
établissements oui j'entends bien
écouter ce que jusque ce que j'entends
moi c'est beaucoup d'inquiétude de
professeurs qui qui pousse qui concerne
l'enseignement public voit effectivement
de réforme en réforme
renier la confusion la déstructuration
et donc
progressivement on se dit on de
l'enseignement public qui ne répond plus
à sa mission la mission d'école c'est
transmettre c'est transmettre des
fondamentaux des connaissances structure
et voilà c'est pas faire garderie ou aux
récréations développement des ateliers
ou des conversations ou des causeries
sur des sujets périphériques donc
j'avais fernagut le pays sur les
cultures anciennes c'est pas assez
suffisant c'est du saupoudrage du latin
et du grec
écoutez je crois que en la matière il
faut rester sérieux
najat vallaud belkacem a déclaré l'autre
jour sur une chaîne de service public
que l'option de latin grec reste est à
l'identique
n'est ce pas
et que les élèves après l'avoir
découvert dans les nouveaux modules qui
reste effectivement mettre en place et
on a encore 15 mans pour y réfléchir et
bien partir du moment où ils ont
découvert les options resterait en
l'état
alors je ne sais pas de quel querelle il
s'agit
concernant les accompagnements
l'accompagnement pédagogique elle suivi
individualisé
qui va effectivement s'inscrire dans une
démarche de relative autonomie des
établissements
quand on parle d'économie
l'établissement de quoi s'agit-il on
garde effectivement 80% des
enseignements qui reste sous l'autorité
de l'état du ministère l'éducation
nationale même si elle est en cas
d'arrêt du sac idéal en fonction de la
spécificité du public accueilli je ne
crois pas que le jeune collégien demande
est forcément la même demande ou la même
façon de vivre son collège que celui de
bondy ou celui neuilly-sur-seine
donc excusez moi je ne parle pas du
département 18
titre d'exemple donc l'accompagnement
pédagogique
ça va permettre effectivement partant
des difficultés exprimées constaté de
l'élève
de pouvoir l'accompagner sur les chemins
de la réussite alors qu'auparavant et
bien à la sortie de l'école il devait se
débrouiller avec un accompagnement
scolaire qui restait à imaginer à la
périphérie de l'école secondaire est
plus ou moins bien est ce que ça peut
marcher quand on connaît peut-être 120
grillé vous avez vous avez l'expérience
des des salles d'enseignement des
professeurs comment on va faire en sorte
que tout le monde puisse se mettre
d'accord pour travailler dans
l'interdisciplinarité pour que le prof
de mathématiques avec le prof d'anglais
prof de français puissent se mettre en
ce moment c'est là où je vais prendre ma
casquette de syndicaliste il ya une
responsabilité de l'employeur terrible
en termes de formation et
d'accompagnement des collègues c'est à
dire que trop souvent quand même des
réformes en place on sort des jolis
textes et puis dans la réalité les
collègues ils se retrouvent seuls très
seuls à devoir mettre en place des
choses pour lesquelles ils ne sont pas
formés et moi ça c'est ma grande crainte
c'est à dire que je pense que la yaris
est un vrai challenge c'est encore un
anglicisme
c'est absolument un défi pour
l'employeur de regagner la confiance de
ses employés de ses enseignants qui sont
quand même des cadres qui sont pas
idiots qu'ils savent faire des choses
mais qui ont terriblement besoin
d'accompagnement d'institutions c'est à
dire que ça suffit de laisser les
collègues tous seuls dans leurs
établissements se débrouillent et ça ce
n'est pas envisageable et là ça
nécessite des moyens ça nécessite du
temps ça nécessite une vraie ambition
une vraie réflexion et on a quinze mois
pour le faire là c'est un vrai défi et
moi je souhaite que ça fonctionne mais
ça ne pourra fonctionner que s'il ya cet
accompagnement de l'institution il va
falloir vraiment travailler là dessus
afin que les corps d'inspection
travaille là dessus il va falloir que
les chefs d'établissement acceptent de
travailler avec leurs enseignants en
équipe ça se fait parfois ça ne se fait
pas partout et ça c'est vraiment
dommageable donc là il ya une vraie
responsabilité de l'institution du temps
et des moyens pour former les
enseignants ne sont pas loin alors moi
je ne suis pas enseignant donc je ne
peux pas aller sur le même terrain en
revanche ce que ce que je crois en
parents d'élèves d'abord et on
responsables politiques aussi c'est que
toute réforme qui ne met pas au coeur de
son projet la volonté de renforcer les
acquis et les connaissances déjà lire
fondamentale des élèves est nulle et non
avenue on voit bien la levée de
boucliers contre 7 contre cette réforme
il faut comme les haies messieurs être
sérieux arrêtez de gesticuler et sans
doute revenir aussi sur cette histoire
de collège unique pour avoir kiffé donc
de l'avenir de l'indifférenciation
pardon pour pouvoir tenir compte à la
fois des différences de niveaux et les
différences d'aspiration des enfants
parce personnalisé des parcours et aider
les uns les autres à franchir à leur
rythme est différent niveau d'un socle
de compétences et de connaissances
commun c'est peut-être ce qui est visé
justement en disant que les classes
latin grec où les classes bilingues dont
on n'a pas parlé aujourd'hui
alors m toujours les mêmes élèves avec
ceux qui ont les petits codes et qui
vont placer leurs enfants dans les
classes qui font du latin du grec ou
bien les classes bilangues et puis du
coup on a qui exclurait non je crois pas
moi en réalité je crois que c'est très
fort mais les idéologique c'est à dire
que après l'interdiction du
renouvellement après le bannissement des
notes après la suppression d atteindre l
excellence voilà on continue d'avancer
vers pardon mais
égalitarisme et du nivellement par le
bas surtout voilà et ça semble vraiment
être le mot d'ordre de gouvernance
socialiste pour l'école nivellement par
le bas et indifférenciation higuita
égalitariste ça vient faire un lieu un
mot pour conclure oui en écoutant
monsieur je pensais si cette refonte de
l'évaluation j'aimerais en rappeler un
petit peu la cie littérale
pour ne pas y perdre son latin sans
faire le jeu de mot idiot elle saluait
sortir la valeur 2 sortir la valeur 2
c'est peut-être sortir aussi d'un
système de notation
vécu par la plupart des acteurs
éducatifs comme un système d'un autre
ange et par les dévaluations ça veut
dire considéré qu'une note de huit et
demi sur 20 c'est peut-être deux points
dessous de la moyenne un point et demi
mais c'est à 6,8 admis au dessus de 20
est à saisir effectivement de ce que
l'enfant extreme de positif et c'est
insuffisant pour effectivement mettre
les choses en synergie de façon à
optimiser cette transmission de savoir
de la façon la plus adaptée qui soit
donc ça c'est sur les valeurs sont
rapidement intégrés rang pour terminer
parce qu'en terminé l'émission adhésif
juste une chose sur des classes
bilangues moi je trouve ça formidable
que les classes bilangues ça soit pour
tout le monde maintenant partir de la
cinquième après il ya des effectivement
le fait que les professeurs d'allemand
risquent de perdre leur poste ces
problématiques mais là il faudra
réfléchir en carte des formations et des
langues merci à tous les trois en tout
cas d'avoir participé à ce débat très
riche très intéressants n'hésitez pas à
vous de votre côté à réagir sur le
twitter de l'émission hashtag 7,8
société on se retrouve dans trois
semaines pour un prochain numéro bonne
soirée à tous